yeah wait we didn't talk to these
americans
you shared a uh a ride with we did no
cause remember we talked about it at the
restaurant but we had a we never talked
to them
yeah oh so when i was in cleveland
celebrity plane
i was sitting there what happened was on
the way over to cleveland
i got like coach and i just felt like
just listen hear me out i always fly
coach
i always do but for once i went you know
what
i got some things going on
i remember when i did here remember i
did why you laughing george
remember i did the um the oddball comedy
tour tour
texas and i showed up at the airport
and because we were all supposed to buy
our own ticket and
dane cook tom segura
sebastian monoskalco and ali wong they
all had first
class tickets and i chose
coach because my agents my managers
can i say it no yes they're great
they're great but she's jewish
so she's out sweetie you're just gonna
it's fine economically
you know you need to save money so i
when i did that i was like this is
embarrassing because i had to walk past
them yeah yeah
yeah when they were in first class so on
the way back i got you know what i call
abby i go
just give me a [ __ ] first class
ticket on the way home so she did it
so i'm sitting there and matthew
mcconaughey
his wife and his two kids came on board
and they sat directly up in back of me
and i was i tried to stare at matthew to
see if he would look at me
because maybe he but he didn't look me
at me
it's fine but you know can i say
something
and i really mean this is not a joke for
the first time
i knew that this plane was going to make
it to lax
why because i believe that when a pilot
knows there's an a-list superstar on the
plane
he tries harder oh hammy for the um kiss
landing
yeah like he literally like was the
landing good amazing
like there was no bumps there was no
turbulence yeah through the whole flight
there wasn't that was a vr simulator
yeah he went like a different direction
god also was like okay don't give him
anything literally you feel like
he's drinking extra coffee yeah he feels
dozing no
no matthew no auto pilot he's not yeah
he just does the whole thing the whole
way
and i felt like that so um i mean
imagine being on a flight with like
a president or you know an ex-president
or
you know someone so you're saying so
you're saying barack obama
has never felt turbulence in his life
nope
you know what someone tweeted at you
when you tweeted about matthew
mcconaughey
um sitting what he said that if well if
the plane crashes you'll only be a
footnote
in the news reports
it's true because everyone's gonna be
like matthew mcconaughey
and then like down all the way like on
the fifth paragraph they're like also
then
bobby lee
sweetie i'm just saying it was a tweet
it was
[Laughter]
it's funny but you're probably right
you're probably right devastating
wouldn't you want to be
like in a plane crash where you're like
the first name right what about this
you know what even be worse what if he's
not on the flight and the car plane
crashes and i'm not mentioned at all
right because let me say something right
now let me say something right now
and it goes back to my power high school
hall of fame thing
that's right okay connects back that
some people don't necessarily think that
i deserve
anything and if i died some people would
be like oh [ __ ] that guy
like poway high school did my high
school
they put all these [ __ ] guys on the
[ __ ] hall of fame
a teacher granted it's a noble job i'm
sure she
saved a lot of lives but i'm the [ __ ]
king i'm probably late
you know i just love king [ __ ] can get
no love
that's all i'm saying i'm sorry honey
what what's the nomination process down
there i want to like get to get an in at
poway high school and like have them i
don't know what it is